et pour en parler nous sommes avec
geneviève pezot historienne spécialiste
des questions liées à l'éducation
auteurs défi chez les garçons
l'apprentissage de la mixité aux
éditions vendémiaire bonsoir je 9e
peseux merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à vos côtés kevin bossuet
professeur d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis bonsoir kevin boss
fait merci à vous également la ministre
un de la citoyenneté a expliqué ce matin
chez nos confrères de bfm que la mixité
sociale était inopérant dans de nombreux
quartiers populaires de france
est ce que cette mère a raison de dire
cela c'est un constat que que vous
partagez vous sur le terrain kevin
bossuet oui c'est évident c'est un
constat en effet que l'on partage en
effet quand on va dans certains
quartiers de certaines banlieues on se
rend compte en effet que dans les
établissements scolaires vous trouve
évidemment des enfants issus du même
milieu social cela s'explique par
différentes manières ça s'explique tout
d'abord par le fait qu'il ya dans
certains quartiers d'edena si vous
voulez de pauvreté ou tout simplement
les gens les moins les plus riches
finalement son parti de ces quartiers
donc forcément ne fréquentent pas les
cartes des blessés des établissements
scolaires de ces quartiers et puis ça
s'explique aussi par une montée du
communautarisme avec en effet de plus en
plus de gens qui fuient ces quartiers à
cause des problèmes d'islamisme à cause
des problèmes en effet de
communautarisme musulman d'où ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
une école à deux vitesses avec dans
certains quartiers en effet des
établissements scolaires on trouve des
catégories socioprofessionnelles
supérieures et d'autres établissements
scolaires on nous trouve presque
uniquement des catégories sociales
intérieures
ouais je ne vienne peuvent eux mêmes
constats vous qui avez écrit un livre
sur sur le sujet il ya vraiment voilà
déjà sur le constatons simplement aucune
mixité dans certains quartiers
aujourd'hui en france oui mais là je
voudrais peut-être revenir sur la notion
de mixité parce que
moi quand je travaille sur la mixité en
fait je travaille sur la mixité de sexe
et ça fait vraiment très peu de temps
que le temps oui c'est au début des
années 1990 seulement que l'on a utilisé
le substantif mixité qui lui même n'est
n'apparaît dans l'histoire et dans les
criques en 1956 dans les cahiers
pédagogiques
quand on parlait de mixité on parlait de
la mixité de sexe et dans les années 90
et bien en fait c'est le milieu
journalistique qui a utilisé ce terme
pour l'associer à la petite et social à
la mixité nique à la mixité géographie
c'était une notion qui est finalement
très flou et qu'ils méritent d'être
interrogés et d'ailleurs dans le système
de notre éducation nationale
on a oublié d'interroger cette notion de
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mixité ça
veut rien dire un mot très flou de la
mixité était à mélange comme un mixeur 1
et on espérait que ce serait de
l'homogénéité naturel que quand c'est
homogène et bien on arrive à de la
justice on arrive à de l'égalité on va
trouver de l' équilibre est en fait cet
équilibre il n'est pas naturel et la
mixité elle nécessite vraiment et à
l'orée de nécessité un véritable travail
de réflexion pour pouvoir éviter la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui
mais tant à l'école que dans le milieu
dans le monde et dans la société
et ça me semble important de revenir sur
cette idée mais qu'est ce que l'on
entend derrière le mot mixité quel bon
jeu kevin postuler vous qui est
également professeur d'histoire je
rappelle que mal à peser et historienne
on a loupé le coche c'est intéressant
d'aller dans le dans le fond parce que
souvent quand on aborde ce type de sujet
on est dans la réaction et pas vraiment
dans les recherches des causes très
profonde c'est important d'indiquer le
coche de ne pas se poser la question
qu'est ce que cette mixité que venir la
mixité sociale
aujourd'hui oui on a évidemment loupé le
coche parce que généralement quand
l'entente mixité sociale en résorbant
terme l'économie quand on raisonne en
terme social on s'interroge en effet sur
la catégorie sociale à laquelle
appartient tel ou tel enfant mais la
vérité c'est que dans certains quartiers
de certaines banlieues
ce qui pose problème c'est le mordre de
mixité culturelle parce qu en effet une
importance de l'islamisation et
l'importance du communautarisme musulman
et finalement dans certains quartiers il
ya les français dits de souche même si
je n'aime pas l'expression qui quitte
ses quartiers parce que forcément il son
sujet par exemple au racisme anti blanc
il ya de plus en plus de juifs également
qu'ils sont obligés de fuir ses
quartiers tout simplement parce qu'ils
sont agressés parce que tout simplement
ils ne sont pas en sécurité d'un
historien qui s'appelle georges
bensoussan qui a montré que 80 % des
juifs et a été obligé de fuir la seine
saint denis
quand on regarde ceux qui sont restés en
seine-saint-denis finalement on se rend
compte que de plus en plus ces gîtes ont
été obligés d'aller dans les
établissements privés tout simplement
parce qu'ils ne trouvent plus leur place
au sein de l'école de la république à
une environ une dizaine d'années en
effet il y avait trois écoles juives
privé en seine saint denis aujourd'hui
il y en a huit donc vous voyez la mixité
sociale ce n'est pas que social c'est
aussi culturel et ce qui pose problème
en effet c'est que la république
n'arrive plus à assimiler sa diversité
on se retrouve si vous voulez avec des
quartiers qui sont des quartiers ghettos
où finalement l'égalité des chances
n'existe plus elle geneviève peseux
quand on entend le diagnostic art de
kevin bossuet qui je le précise il le
rappelle est professeur d'histoire en
seine saint denis qui constate selon lui
en tout cas ce genre de phénomène vous
vous dites quoi on aurait voilà dû
s'interroger sur des notions de mixité
qu'est ce que ça aurait changé qu'est ce
qu'on aurait dû faire de différent pour
éviter cela et le délire c'est amusant
dans vous entendant parce que le thème
mixité le substantif il ne se traduit
pas en anglais on est obligé de passer
par le mot diversité pour travailler sur
ces questions
ces questions de mélange entre cultures
différentes qui qui vivent ensemble dans
des les mêmes lieux alors je crois
vraiment que en tête
ce questionnement qui naquit arrive trop
tard peut-être puisqu'il il émerge
aujourd'hui en effet ça n'empêche pas
que certains aient beaucoup travaillé
sur ces questions là dans les années 90
et 2000 mais n'ont pas été forcément
entendu ces questions là elles elles
vont passer quand on parle de mixité
culturelle qui on veut une mixité sa
part évidemment par l'éducation
il n'ya pas c'est pas les générations
des parents des adultes des personnes
qui sont arrivés au cours de leur vie en
france qui vont être en capacité de
rentrer dans une phase d'intégration
parce que finalement c'est l'idée
derrière c'est que s'il y avait eu un
bon mélange entre les populations
on ne réussirait a aussi intégré toutes
les populations elle se sentirait est
accueilli et elle pourrait jouer le jeu
de cette et inventer une société qui vit
correctement ensemble parce que c'est le
bien vivre ensemble qui est à nouveau
interrogé avec cette notion de de
mélange d d alors des personnes qui
viennent d'ailleurs ou qui sont d'une
culture qui n'est pas comme vous disiez
originaire de l'est de la france mais
qui sont aussi des atouts incroyable
pour nous enrichir
et c'est là où moi je pense que c'est
pas trop tard mais il faut prendre le
taureau par les cornes et de toute façon
comme vous le disiez une histoire
récente fait que comme on ne l'a pas
bien anticipé ou est ce que c'est une
question d'aménagement du territoire
aussi on a on a repoussé les les
familles les ouïes personnes qui se
ressemblent entre elles
on les a on leur a proposé de vivre dans
les mêmes lieux mais ça à partir d'un
certain niveau d'une certaine quantité
de personnes on se retrouve exclue ou
n'appartenant pas à ce groupe là est
donc on s'en va
et on crée des communautés alors la mère
de famille qui interpellait emmanuel
macron expliqué je cite que c'était
différent
à son époque c'est quelque chose en vous
est peut-être un peu trop jeune pour
l'avoir constaté kevin bossuet mais
peut-être le savez vous tout de même ces
phénomènes de non-mixité un non on n'est
pas cette contandin pas ce mot il s'est
accentué ces dernières années c'est vrai
qu'il s'est accentuée des mêmes
récemment les plus jeunes ont peut-être
constaté d'ailleurs
oui en effet c'est un phénomène qui
s'est accéléré on voit bien en effet
qu'on a en france une école qui est
profondément inégalitaire où finalement
l'école est le principal outil de la
reproduction sociale et tout ça
forcément c'est dû au fait qu'il ya un
manque de missiles de mixité sociale et
le fait également en effet que tout le
monde n'a pas les mêmes chances dès le
départ sinon j'aimerais revenir sur ce
qu'a dit votre interlocutrice votre
interlocutrice parle notamment
d'intégration mais il est là le problème
c'est finalement c'est que le problème
c'est que on a on a voulu faire de
l'intégration d'eds c'était important
c'est de faire de la simulation le
problème au sein de l'école de la
république c'est qu'il n'y a plus de
vivre en ce sens et que les jeunes ne
partage plus les mêmes valeurs et quand
j'entends votre interlocutrice nous dire
que finalement on a parqué les gens de
même origine ethnique dans les mêmes
endroits s'est pas fait c'est qu'au
départ il y avait une mixité sociale
sauf qu'avec une montée du
communautarisme musulman avec une montée
de l'islamisme est forcément ceux qui
pouvaient partir sont profondément
partie vous savez c'est ce qui a mis en
avant le politiste laurent bouvet qui
parlait d'un sécurité culturelle c'est
vrai que pour une partie de la
population vivent sur des territoires où
finalement on a plus l'impression d'être
en france dès forcément c'est
excessivement compliqué donc ces gens
sont partis pour essayer pour tout
simplement aller ailleurs et ce qu'il ya
de dramatique finalement au sein de
l'école de la république c'est cette
école de l'aide à deux vitesses et qu'on
a des parties du territoire français où
on peut convenablement enseigner les
programmes de l'éducation nationale il y
en ad'autres finalement ne peut plus
enseigner correctement les programmes de
l'éducation nationale on peut plus dans
certains quartiers ont signé là choix on
peut plus dense dans certains quartiers
enseigner d'égalité homme femme un peu
plus dans certains cas qui est enseigné
notamment la la
reproduction sexuelle tout simplement
parce qu'il ya une telle présence de
l'islam ici et elles présence de la
religion musulmane que finalement ça
devient compliqué pour les professeurs
en effet de faire leur travail je
rappelle qu'il ya un sondage qui est
sorti il ya quelques mois qui a montré
qu un enseignant sur deux
s'autocensurent donc se quitter qu'on se
retrouve avec sur certaines parties du
territoire une école dans laquelle on
peut enseigner correctement les choses
et de l'autre sur d'autres parties du
territoire pour reprendre une expression
de vincent peillon alors qu'il était
ministre de l'éducation nationale
finalement une école où on ne peut plus
enseigner tout ce que l'on veut
enseigner c'est ça qui est dommage
alors pourquoi péter à votre propos je
voudrais vous faire écouter et robert
ménard maire est reine de béziers sur
son diagnostic
posons la seule vraie question pourquoi
tant de pierre ne veulent pas vivre avec
autant de mohamed de plus en plus de
parents musulmans on voit leurs enfants
dans les écoles privées catholiques
tout le monde fuit ces écoles sont
pierre la réalité c'est que la plupart
des pierres ne veulent plus fréquenté
ces écoles et leur part ont encore mon
jeu 9e 11e c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de répondre et vous les avez
vous qui avez étudié longuement sur ces
questions les réponses à ces questions
que pose le maire de béziers et aussi
kevin bossuet dans un sens ce qu'il ya
un problème tout simplement voilà de
religion de communautarisme et c'est
tout simplement ça qui a fait fuir aussi
les autres personnes alors j'ai très
envie de reprendre la parole bac je
pense que là on est dans un discours pré
polémiste qui fait que re monter la
mayonnaise
on est à la limite qui est réelle en
france aujourd'hui qui est responsable
d'une bonne idée et qu'il ne faut pas
éluder
non mais au contraire et il faut le
prendre à bras le corps mais je pense
qu'on pose la question d'une pas
correctement
déjà quand on parle d'assimilation
comment et pourquoi assimilé il faut
intégrer et que chacun et chacune trouve
avec ce qu'il a en elle et en lui donc
avec sa culture sa place et il ya depuis
trop longtemps
ce désir profond que on doit devenir
français tels que on imagine ce que
donne
être un français etc ça sans doute une
des grosses d'erreurs que l'on fait et
que l'on continue à faire les discours
de droite en france le cloud et les
discours de gauche ne sont pas assez
courageux pour prendre ce sujet
finalement à bras le coeur et à bras le
corps l'intégration c'est à la fois
respecter la culture de chacun et de
chacune et réussir à ce que on trouve sa
place et que l'on fabrique que l'on
arrive à réinventer une culture communes
dans lesquelles ils peuvent trouver leur
plaque
je pense que il y à un autre problème et
c'est là où c'est la grosse difficulté
pour les enseignants et des enseignantes
dans les dents les les cités et les
quartiers qui reçoivent des populations
qui viennent avec des cultures autres en
grand nombre c'est une question de masse
qui ce qui s'est créée
d'autant qu' il y à un courant et un
mouvement mais qui n'est pas français il
est international
c'est ce courant vert unissent la mine
où l islam qui n'est plus dans la
tolérance qui s'est figé dans des
réactions
j'allais dire réactionnaire enfin dans
des positions intégristes islam
intégriste qui a gangréné une grande
partie de cette population parce qu'
elle n'a pas trouvé sa place
correctement dans notre société en
développés ou en développement ou en
tout cas qui accueille d une migraine
l'immigration économique
kevin tuer nos maux d'un pardonnez moi
parce qu'on arrive oui à l'issue c'est
très intéressant effectivement et
j'aurais j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
de vous re est invité pour développer
ces thèmes effectivement kevin bossuet
le mot de la fin en substance à ce que
c'est la faute au monde occidental qui
n'a pas su bien
accueillir c'est différent de conclure
non mais ici dans le discours de la
gauche bien pensante qui a tué l'école
de la république parce que la vérité
c'est qu'on n'y pas ici dans le
reniement des cultures d'origine
évidemment qu'un les lèvres est fière de
sa culture d'origine me voit aussi ce
sport français madame je vous invite si
vous voulez dans une classe d'un collège
ou d'un lycée de seine-saint-denis et
vous verrez que vous mangez un plus
franc qui disons permanent nique la
france je n'aime pas la france et ça
pose un problème quand on est dans le
reniement d'un pays qui les a accueillis
même d'un pays qui les amenait donc à un
moment il faut réaffirmer la république
il faut faire en sorte de faire régner
ses lois au sein de ces cités parce que
les élèves de france quelle que soit
leur origine sociale quelles que soient
leurs origines ethniques ont le droit à
la même éducation et quand je vous
entends madame vous est symptomatique du
mal français et je me rends compte à
quel point la gauche de l'éducation est
l'ennemi des classes populaires et
l'ennemi en effet des élèves d'origine
immigrée c'est dramatique
allez aimer ça vaudrait le coup que l'on
aille plus loin mais je trouve que vous
m'attaquez de façon un peu un peu
frontale vous respecte mais c'est mon
discours j'attaque parce que ça fait des
années qu'on entend toujours le même
discours et votre discours et d'allemand
vous proposer quelques mots pour moi
j'ai tout simplement je propose que l'on
réaffirmé lois de la république sur le
terrain on lui contre l'islamisme qu'on
lutte contre le cube une otarie ce qu'on
fait en sorte que ces gamins se sentent
de nouveau français qu'on recréer du
vivre donc vive l'école de la république
vive la méritocratie et l'assimilation
merci vous avez eu l'occasion d'exprimer
en tout cas de tous les deux votre point
de vue j'espère effectivement qu on
reste un peu sur notre faim mais
malheureusement on arrive à l'issue de
ce débat qu'on a déjà prolongé merci en
tout cas tous les deux je ne viens un
peu ce et et kevin bossuet d'avoir été
avec nous et on
l'occasion vous réinviter en tout cas
merci à vous